it's obviously you were pro each of you
got involved in a different way but i'm
just so curious what is it like because
this is not material that comes around
that often with the way it takes
different tone and the way it brings
it's just a different kind of script so
for both of you what was it like reading
something like this for the first time
and did you have any i did someone warn
you by the way after page 30 it's taking
a complete left turn i guess i gotta
give shout out to my agent houston costa
he
presented the opportunity and i read the
script and i told i even told mimi when
we met and that's another reason mimi
and i had a general
before i even auditioned i believe and
we clicked that we hit it off and i i
remember telling you i feel like this is
a movie
my dad and i would watch together like
we it was a thing as a kid to go get a
blockbuster movie and get chinese food
and you know i was like this feels like
one we were watching the dark as a
family i probably wouldn't watch it
alone you know it probably would be a
group thing so i immediately connected
with it and then you know of course
hearing that daisy and sebastian are
involved as well and then you fall in
love with the director i was like i pray
i get this you know and
i was really really interested in molly
because um
you know she was a
she was similar to me but different than
anything i've played i played so far so
at that time so it was a big deal yeah
and then for me uh you know i think like
like you said it's just such a bold and
unique script and i knew that right away
i
had trouble reading it it stuck with me
it like really scared uh the living
daylight out of me in a couple different
ways and so i think
you know when you read something like
that that does scare you and scares you
to take it on um
i feel like that's when you know you're
onto something
and
it's when you know you can kind of like
be alive in the challenge that is
presented to you so
um there was a lot of reasons why i
wanted to kind of try it out and take it
on and i just got really lucky in terms
of being able to have
incredible producers and writer lauren
who
believed that i could do it and so um
yeah i normally don't ask this question
but how have both of you been describing
this film to friends and family because
it's like the less you know the better
but you still have to tell people to
watch it
yes
yeah i just i bribe people
[Laughter]
yeah just hold them down and say you
better watch it no
i don't actually know this is the
hardest question that i've ever had and
for the last year i still haven't been
able to figure out how to summarize it
without giving anything away
um you know i think it's it's being said
that it's like a modern dating horror
film about perils of modern dating and
to be honest i just think it's like it's
a wild ride of a movie and i think
prefacing it with i'm not gonna say
anything because it's better if you
don't know is i don't know i feel like
that's enough yeah
um yeah i'm very vague i try to keep it
very open-ended i say you know it's a
thriller
it's a scary movie um which shout out to
you and whoever edited the trailer
because i think they did an incredible
job
mark wallin yeah shout out to mark
um i think he did an incredible job
telling what the movie was about but not
telling what the movie is about you know
very much so like opens up your
curiosity and you see things happening
and but don't have a clue so
that's been tough for me to even talk
about so for him to
do a trailer i was like okay
i feel like you're just like go watch it
i'm amazing i'm in it yeah
what else
yeah like
jojo's enough that's all you need yes
i love talking to directors about the
editing process because ultimately
that's the final rewrite and the thing
about this movie is you're playing with
some different tones in the first act
and then it's like basically a different
movie can you sort of talk about the
challenges you ran into in the editing
room and you know putting this thing
together you know i don't know we had a
lot of fun in the editing room to be
honest um we you know our editor is
editing as we're shooting so a lot of
troubles or challenges we came up
against we were able to solve
um or find a new way of approaching it
while we were shooting so was very lucky
to be able to do that the editor martin
pensa who did dallas buyers club and
wild he's just like his own maestro
artist um
so you know seeing the first assembly
he had already thrown in some pretty
like amazing artistic ideas and i was
just thinking today earlier i was like
i miss just being in the room with
martin
so we just had such a great time
together and and i think like again just
as the script gave me so much material
to mold like
the footage and the performances
there was really just so much fun to be
had something else about the film that
uh um for both of you actually uh was
there a sequence that ended up being
like which was the one that was the real
pain in the ass to film was there one or
was it actually like a smooth sailing
shoot for an entire week we shot in the
woods at night and i think that was the
most taxing for everybody physically
and because a lot of it was action
sequences um
that makes it even harder and we were
dealing with weather and really low
temperatures and just a lot of different
and prosthetics and all sorts of things
so i think those were the most sort of
challenging days um to sort of keep our
heads on straight because we were
filming the end of the movie in the
middle of filming so
yeah i think i think that was
the the sort of like the most
trying week yes yes and y'all were
considering getting a rain machine and i
was like
no please
please don't do us like that
um so no that didn't happen but um
the most trying scene for me it didn't
make it into the film but i um oh yeah i
broke the top of my heel bone in a scene
with sebastian um because sebastian is
so brave and so about the performance
like
i was kind of you know
to
the pitter patter around because the you
know the stunt guy was like yeah you're
getting too close to my face and i'm
like like i'm not gonna hit you chill
out you know and sebastian would come in
and be like just come at me just
whatever you feel hit me just do it just
whatever and i'm like you just gave the
wrong person a green light
okay
we can do that and it was a very uh
intense scene great scene i completely
forgot that i was chained to the floor
and um
yeah i i went flew in the air and landed
on her heel yeah and it was uh
in an earlier cut of the film it was it
was in the film and it was um
it's painful for me to watch because i
know what's actually happening yeah it
was the best take though it was so funny
what's so funny is after i hit the
ground i looked for the camera i was
like can they still see me okay okay
she stayed in it
and then i remember like hearing myself
when we cut i can hear myself going jojo
and i like ran in and i'm like are you
okay
when everyone ran and i was like okay
they could tell that that was not not
okay yeah
she did she took one for the team for
sure yeah uh method acting sometimes it
goes wrong
something for the blue ray on that note
i got to stop i'm just going to say
congrats on the movie you guys did a
great job hope it's a huge hit for you
guys thank you so much
cool thank you